hi I'm Matt Kelly there's gonna be a few
visuals in here so you won't have to
read so much text hopefully but the
project for the incentive award that I
did was visualizing digital collections
of web archives so the problem we
basically want to solve is for sites
that when you put a URI into something
you don't know initially what you're
going to get fat and if say that's been
archived over time all the site likely
changes and so we want to do is try to
get the aboutness of the site as change
over time so in this case with apple how
it's changed your math drastically over
the maybe 20 years that it's existed so
but if we try to do that for every
moment that we have apple has about
17,000 Mentos in in our archive alone
not counting the other archives I'm so
trying to do this for all of these
different screenshots is very expensive
in addition to that there's also many
redundancies as you can see from the
ones that are circled here there is not
necessarily useful to see these
redundant mentis we're trying to get a
summarization for what the site has been
about over time and how it's changed um
so there's a couple different methods of
summarization that you can use to do
this can include all the mementos as I
said before it's a very expensive both
temporally spatially and cognitively
expensive to actually look this
collection of many different screenshots
and try to get what the gist is of how
it's changed but if you try to randomly
pick mementos from the collection that
you receive you end up missing important
captures that are that a representative
of how the page has changed in addition
to that doing image differentials trying
to figure out how the painters change by
comparing every single memento is a very
template expensive to generate all those
but also do the image differential so
what we actually came up with in our
research was to take the text content of
these different Mentos compare them in
account with a summarization based on
the HTML of the pages so in the case of
this this individual Apple memento that
you see here we can crawl that and we
can get totally the HTML without having
this petrol and the other resources that
are associated with it from that we
generate a sim hash value a sim patch
value is a means of a sort of
fingerprinting the the markup in this
case but it's meant more to identify
similarities between different text
contents rather than differences like
other hashes so
let me go over stimpacks a little bit so
if you have an HTML snippet here it
actually chopped up the HTML and
generates a single character for it so
this project was just 64 bits impasse to
compare the different Mentos and so in
this case this moment to be represented
by c3 and many other characters then 9f
one here I'm so comparing sim half to a
couple different hashing algorithm
algorithms on the case of md5 have two
things that are very similar here so the
talk when you see a bunch of a is there
with the blue a highlighter and be in
the second one that's the same string
you get a radically different strings as
outputs in it so comparing conventional
hashes to sim hash you actually want to
find the similarity between through
either then identify subtle differences
so in sim hash you see the a that's a
representative there generates this C 3
character but if you run that same
string with the be substituted you get
the a4 but you get very similar other
characters in the results for so the
basis of this is if we have two
different HTML pages and they've changed
over time to be able to identify the
similarities between these different
mementos we can identify the parts that
have changed and if they've gotten past
a certain threshold and they have note
they've changed to a sufficient degree
to warrant them being included in
summarization so like I said we want to
identify the similarities rather than
difference in this and we want to remove
the redundancies that we saw any 17,000
apple screen shots by using the basis
that if the sim passage are very similar
then it's likely that the screenshots
are going to be very similar and not
contribute to the badness of the page in
the summary of the page how it's changed
over time so for this impasse that we
saw before if we have these forward to
mementos for apple com what were you can
see the subtle differences in here but
if we actually highlight them in here
you can see that if we have a sim hash
if we have a threshold to be of
differences we call the Hamming distance
in here so Hamming distance is merely
the change in two different strings as
if compared so in the top one we use
that as a basis to the pivot in that
case so in the second one there the
second memento from March fifth 2008 we
see two different characters to change
but that's not enough to pass our
threshold of four characters changing in
a 64-bit sim hash two weren't including
that
that memento in the summary so in the
third one you can see that one character
is chained from the pivot that D whereas
its compared April twelfth is compared
to March third rather than March 5th
since march trip isn't included in the
summary and finally on october for 2008
the simp ash has changed drastically so
in that case that would would be the
first men today you'd want to include in
the summary beyond the pivot value so in
this case we would include for this one
as a partial the reputation of the time
app the March third 2008 and the October
for 2008 any other ones that pass the
threshold of Hamming distance so to kind
of visualize the Hamming distance
threshold on whenever it passes little
dotted line there with a sliding pivot
basis than it is included in it so the
red circled ones as we saw before
momenta three would be included and then
everything subsequent to that until we
included another Mentos would be based
on momenta three as as its pivot so we'd
have meant to three minutes of six and
momenta a tenant here so to sort of
explain that a little better it shows
that we use a sliding pivot in this case
so everything prior to momenta through
we based off of some initial pivot so
since the partial time map we'd have
something before and we include the
first Mentos as a representation of
being included it since we need to need
a pivot to calculate the Hamming
distance so our project goals for this
where we are taking this concept to
develop a to develop a means of
summarizing you are eyes in the archive
so to do this we are about our products
of this this grant were to develop a web
service away back add on an embeddable
version so you can actually use this on
your own do our eyes and we've done that
and I'll the moment here as well as some
screencast I can show you that does in
fact work so the name that we actually
came out with this was called out
summarization this is the works based
off of Ahmed Al sommes ici our 2014
paper regarding coming off summarization
techniques for web archive so it's a sum
plus summarization is el summarization
to just work so as an example of the
another one the pies on this project dr.
Nelson who many of you know we'll use
hem is sort of the base case for what's
include here so what actually looks like
here is oh I guess it's not going to
come
so this we have three different
visualizations in this you can come at
it from different perspectives so this
we're actually showing because it looks
pretty cover flow so the cover flow if
you've seen in itunes before it it makes
it look really pretty but it's really
hard to see what you're getting for the
for the thumbnails so we allow other
presentations are the same data from it
but if you actually want to show
something your cell you say hey this is
how my site looked over time and you can
navigate this thing you can you can
chose to use you know be more impressed
in something flat in this case so dr.
Nelson's page would look like this in
here so tight then five sort of the
parts of this visualization we have the
temporary sort of mementos from the
archives were returned that's the
temporal sorting of it the ones that are
included in the visualization here are
the ones that have been selected to be
sufficiently different from from one
another pass at Hamming distance
threshold being put in the summary so
despite some of those on the Left we're
seeing still have has his avatar there
the textual content was enough to to
pass the Hamming distance partial to
include it in the summary below the
visualization we have some metadata
about the memento itself the you are I
am there as well as the memento datetime
the same hash value that we developed in
the Hamming distance threshold so you
can see that this one here that had
actually highlighted in the middle ahead
of him distance threshold of four so
just met that requirement to be
sufficiently different than the previous
pivot to be included in the summary and
finally on the bottom left there we have
three of a potentially extensible a
number of visualizations for the same
data all these three uses same data set
doesn't have to go back to the server to
perform this process again and I'll show
you a little bit more about what those
different visualizations of the same
data some of which are more effective
and some give a little more information
as to the aboutness of the page over
time so we the service that we set up to
do this we have two different parameters
in addition to the uri are that you're
you are a are that you would specify you
are being the live web URI the the URL
that you type into your web address we
have the access parameter so if you want
to get this visualization here we have
the three different means of showing the
data use interactive one or you just
don't specify anything at all because
these are optional embed allows you to
actually include this service the
product of the service in your website
so you can see how your site has changed
over time using these visualization
aspects simply by including a little
code snippet here you can utilize the
surface on the web as well as way back
we
create an extension to way back that
actually allows you to do this for the
contents of a Wayback Machine instance
in use that as a basis for showing the
contents for that you are I are in
addition to that we also investigate a
couple other strategies some naive some
not so the awesomer station strategy
which we've developed in this research
with a yearly allows you to actually go
through and pick one per year and then
backfill that until we have enough met
those two to pass this threshold she'd
go if it start from 96 96 we didn't have
a 97 you went having a then 98 you'd
pick one and you keep going to get it
and they backfill enough from the most
current ones it's you get it it's just
another summarization strategy on a skip
list that actually picks every que
momento so if you have the time app you
want to pick every fifth mentor you can
go and do that again these are naive
strategies but we're comparing then them
against our sim hash based strategy to a
sort of the basis for what should be
included in summarization as well as
random basically you have a bunch of
mentos and you want to pick random ones
and see if that beats our strategy for
it so to actually do this you can set up
a service is all open source software
and I'll explain a little more in here
are you pass parameters by at the query
string in this case you see access
equals way back and you are I are equals
dr. Nelson site if we want to specify
another parameter again and everything
but the URI are is optional because
there are smart defaults in this then
you can pass access equals way back in
strategy equals random in that case you
get the way back interface to this
service as well as using the random
strategy so these are really easy to
toggle in there and as Walters the
interface that makes it see I have the
type anything URL bar but it makes it
pretty simple to internet faced with
this server so sort of the inner
workings of the service its user goes to
goods or web browser types in one of the
URLs you saw before it sends a request
the service the service then goes to in
this case is in our archive that
standard too but really any momento
compliant archive should work for it is
you can basically change one value at
beginning the code and use it for you an
archive or your own local instance of
way back and so from that URI are that
the user requested to it the service
then goes and queries the archive to get
all the mentors for that you I are so
much return is time Apfel you are IMS
and so the service takes us and starts
turning on it and what it does is it
goes and fetches the HTML of all these
different mentis which is fairly
temporally expensive operation but in
you get a better summarization for so
that's the most expensive part that
we're still trying to get over for it
but basically it has to go through every
single one just to get the text contents
but that it can cash it and from there
it's from the server side cash it can
overcome that that limitation on us so
once it has that it generates a sim hash
for each of these minutes isn't the time
app and from that it calculates the
Hamming distance that we saw before
tries to figure out the mementos that
passed the threshold in this case the
the first and the fourth one pass it and
again this is a very small time map for
what some of the sites that come back
since k5 event is you know our home
pages have more than 50 mentis in the
archive at this point so there's sort of
a set part of the time app so so before
actually creating these thumbnails the
screenshots a preliminary interface is
returned to the user that has
placeholder since we already know how
many images are going to be in the
center is a shin we can set up this
visualization and then populate
asynchronously as the thumbnails are
generated so to give kind of a response
response designed to the user we return
the visualization with the placeholders
on it and basically can have automated
84 it just the images aren't generated
yet and then the service goes and this
is all the user doesn't have to do
anything further everything is populated
after this it wasn't generates a
thumbnails for each of the Mentos that
it had previously chosen to include in
the summarization using phantom jas in
this case but you can plug any any one
of your screenshot generating services
that you want here basically just pass
it through a parameter because you
already know the URI MS in this case
once those are generated and really the
thumbnail generation ironically takes
less time to complete then the sim hash
generation but it's it's one of those
things that is just expensive processing
at front but more benefit in the end the
only to do it once so it's a lot of
overhead for it so once we have all the
screenshots or the thumbnails we return
that's the interface into asynchronously
populated so you see all these things
start popping up on here there were
previously placeholders and you get the
full interface mind you all the stuff is
cash it was just initial expense of
front and then once you have that then
it doesn't need to be regenerated again
sort of to accomplish this we used
nodejs for it it's a framework that
allows you to to be it's very very sick
nurse JavaScript based framework that's
meant for a server-side thing but it
handles requests very uh without
necessarily getting bought
down on a single sort of requests
phantom Jas to generate the screenshots
again you can substitute your choice
when we coded this up we made a very
modular and very semantic so we can
reuse a lot of these memento
abstractions that we have in here so
we're hoping to take these mental
abstractions that we coded in java
script and apply them to some other
projects that we have since it are a
kind of has the interfaces that you'd
have on momento objects without having
any um any too tight coupling with the
service itself as well as that it's an
open source project so everything is
documented in hopes that we'll get some
polar quest and improve the services to
make it more useful for other people so
again fork me on github please so it's
actually stall the service if you never
first you'd actually install node on
here so you can still know it on your
service on your under your PC unison on
your pc or server to install
dependencies npm install installs
everything that's needs to be included
for this and you simply take no doubt
summarization and the service up and
running so you actually get the output
on the bottom here that just gives you
kind of information on how to access it
so in this case if you want to do for my
own site you'd simply go to that URI in
the browser and that's just something
because I installed it on localhost to
show it so basically tell you what host
you need to go to where you have to go
in your in your web browser or where you
need to curl or however you want to
interface with it that's where you need
to go for it so although about this
online versus offline generation of the
a lot of expenses in the online
generation basically you're doing this
on the fly as the users come but you can
pre generate a lot of this stuff and
amend these these sim hash caches that
you get back because it's going to for
the most part just be included on the
end basically appended on to this impact
crash so if say you you do it one day
and then a year later you go and you
want to get another summarization for it
to include this new fancy design you
have on your website that you've
archived through one of the various
services you can run it again and it
will go and fetch the updated time app
in amend it will know that you already
have the same hash for all these do not
do it again and amend your send Hashcash
and you basically have to generate one
more screenshot because everything else
stored on the server word of where the
service is located rather on your
machine or anything like that offline
summarization in contrast is where you
actually pre generalized stuff you feed
a big list of your eyes you basically
say I want thumbnail summer stations for
say all these your eyes and Alexa five
and I want to make sure to I'm expecting
people to come and look at these
summarization so I want to pre generate
these so that's capable of doing this
machine as well and it makes it so it's
not necessarily on demand but it makes
it so it's more responsive whenever
someone comes if they come in the energy
or I that isn't include that it will
default to online generation and then
you'll have that within your data set
there's a couple different adaptive
strategies so generating all these uh
these sim patches is extremely expensive
so there's actually a by default if you
don't specify a strategy it will first
try out summarization and if there's a
certain threshold of mementos we're
going to take like ours to generate it
will go to a naive strategy and actually
do something like like random and give
you back a summarization to get over
that you can actually explicitly state
that you want out summarization and it
will go and grind for those hours to go
and generate always a screen shots but
it gives sort of am a way to be adaptive
and more usable in this case so if you
just want to get something up real quick
can you want to see it you can do that
so the other different strategies I
talked about before the random strategy
where you pick the k2 Mentos and we get
a uniform selection over the whole time
at the interval every every m-f momento
we get we pick a we picked that and
include that in the summarization and a
temporal interval where we go out year
year year until we have enough Mentos
and if we need to be back built from the
current so when we hear a compact
comparing it we did a couple studies on
to what is a more than more than
sufficient cognitive load to look at a
bunch of thumbnails where that threshold
is about k equals 15 or anything above
that then then it's kind of hard to say
to visualize those all at once for
example that the apple one where you had
maybe a maybe 120 momentous beginning
it's hard to really see which ones are
the unique ones if they all similar in
this case so to be able to take this all
in at once one of the findings were not
from Mars but from previous work and we
use that as a basis as kegels 15 so in
this case we compared dr. Nelson's
homepage over time to a couple of
different strategies so on the right you
can see the grid view which is a little
more informative than the cover flow
view which is not as pretty of course
and this one to attract people to your
site versus the cover flow of you but it
allows you to see the summarization a
little better so see the one on the left
is the random strategy and despite
the randomness you still get a lot of
this very early mentos again these are
temporarily sorted so you get the big
red page in the top left for the random
strategy which were just picked because
of uniform randomness but in our
strategy of a summarization you can see
that those very similar Mentos were not
included in summary because they were
they did not pass the threshold to be
included so there's only one of those
because the page basically didn't change
I'm you can see some of the other Mentos
for example the one in the top row third
and fourth column there look very
similar but the somewhere on the page
there wasn't enough of a difference for
Jack's be included a second one so maybe
he was doing a little change on the
footer or maybe some of the text content
that made it look different but you can
see that some of the other ones nearby
if you look a little closer you can see
that each consecutive memento looks
slightly different than the last one if
not drastically different versus the
previous one you see identical
consecutive mementos more frequently so
that's just for the random strategy so
if you actually use use the interval
shred you get a similar thing because he
kept that page over time you're getting
you're getting try the intervals every
every every case memento you're getting
the same ones over and over again so
ideally the interval and the temporal
interval should should match up in the
end so in the temporary neural you get
something very similar just basically
because he had that same page for the
longest amount of time you get the same
screen shots over and over again so
again these are very naive strategies
but because he had such a high
concentration you say mementos in there
our method actually does not include
those in for good reason because they
don't actually give you any information
about the badness of the page I've got
the asynchronous polling and you can see
this on here Josh you've done this live
so you can say it because I think
they'll be more useful we got way back
integration so it looks like in here and
that's fully customizable and how you
would include it in the service
embedding as well as you can include it
in page use an object or I frame from
html5 the code base is available here
there's actually a live service up where
you can use it for you and if you just
want to put in bed on your site and try
it and i'm going to try a very quick
live demo because i am short on time so
this is the different visualizations you
can go through here and again this is
live you can see it's on the web on a
she's at dr. instance so if you want to
run this on dr. you can we stood up to
do that we have the grid view as well
which is a different view you get them
made a data by clicking on these and see
that sort of thing as well as we got a
time line display here where you can
actually zoom in and get the
concentration of mentos over time so and
these are supposed to be a little
thumbnails but something is broken in
the code so yeah you can see doc Nelson
had a lot of pages around those red ones
that you saw before were like 2003 or
something like that and because of the
high concentration she got a lot of red
ones and the more naive strategy so with
that I guess I'm done hi I'm Michelle
wagle and I am going to talk about this
project that was primary primarily you
know the work is mostly done by our PhD
students so by yes mean and joint work
with Michael Nelson and first off I want
to thank again columbia university
libraries and mellon Foundation for
funding this work we appreciate any time
that we can get support for our PhD
students to further their dissertation
work and further their academic careers
so thank you so our large title of the
project was tools for managing seed you
our eyes and the real title what are the
tool that we built was a tool to help
you detect off topic pages in your
collections so we've all heard about
archive it today and you know many of
you are very familiar with this service
so they host these curated web
collections and so here's the user view
if you want to go and look at archive it
and if you're a curator here's your view
so and we saw this with the start crawl
now button got pressed and so what our
kind that lets you do is you specified
your seed your eyes for your collection
and then you can specify how frequently
or how deep you want these crawled and
then you know archive it goes off and
crawls and you know you can start these
into that
and five and come back ten years later
and want to analyze it and there's
they're still data there but they
archive it also gives you nice tools to
be able to look and see what's in your
collection when have you collected there
are things here shown in this image on
file type you can also get information
about when pages of 40 Ford but the
thing that we wanted to look at is the
aboutness of the page so when is the
page going off-topic from that original
seed that you want it in your collection
so this is you know may basically aimed
at curators in how to you know maybe
there are pages you want to take out of
your collection because they aren't
reinforcing where your collection is
about so we all know that pages can
change through time they can have subtle
changes but they can also just go off
topic and so this is a page from the
Egyptian revolution in politics site and
this is one of the presidential
candidates of that time and later there
was a database error and then yes mean
promises that this Arabic says there was
a financial problem then it came back on
topic they got everything fixed but it
had a site redesign then the site was
hacked and currently the domain has
expired so from this one page over sixty
percent of the archived versions at
archived it for this page are actually
off topic now if you're a curator you
may want to save the version where the
page was hacked that might have some
historical value for you but you
probably don't want the database error
you probably don't want the financial
error and I'm sure you don't want the
domain has expired error so how do you
find these and you know this can be a
problem in your pages so social media
pages can also go off topic we found so
this is one from the Occupy collection
and a little bit later it redirects just
to facebook com so either the account
was taken down or made private or or
something but you can
access this page the thing that the
crawler grabs now is just the you know
facebook.com template so what do these
web pages look like over time so we've
been introduced to this terminology
before but just one more time so a time
map is the list of a you are eyes
mementos and I'm going to use the the
memento and time at terminology here a
lot so all the times that this page has
been captured and so when we were
looking at how these time maps change we
identified it five different classes in
terms of is it on topic or is it off
topic we have always on stem function on
where it starts on topic and then goes
off topic and remains off topic step
function off where it starts off topic
and then becomes on topic oscillating
like the example I showed where it goes
on and off and then always off so yes
there are some pages that this de seed
was just bad so it never actually was on
topic and we have real world examples of
all of these here on the slide so just a
couple quick examples so the step
function on this is about the Egyptian
revolution and then at some point the
domain registration is lost and actually
if you see the number of the Mintos and
the red boxes are greater than the
number in the green boxes so you have a
lot of mementos here that are not going
to be on topic for you another case we
have is an oscillating exciting so we
saw the one previously where there were
errors in the site but there are also
just topic changes so this is the time
map from the BBC's Middle East page and
this is from the Egyptian revolution
collection so maybe the curator only
wants those BBC pages that show the
Egyptian revolution on the front page
this page actually talks about all sorts
of stuff so we've identified some places
where it was about Iraq or Syria or
Palestine but then it came back and
there were certain places where it was
actually about Egypt
so the curator may want to call those
that are not necess even though there's
nothing wrong with the page itself so
what we found is we looked at I think
this is from about 15,000 mementos from
three collections that we looked at and
we found that most time maps are always
on so that's good so there there there
but there's a pretty significant number
where these off topic pages sneak in so
eight to eleven percent or step function
on so something has happened to the page
and you have a you know generous set of
off-topic things and if that page is
still being crawled you're continually
adding to the number of off topic
mementos a few step function off and
then also a pretty significant number of
these oscillating ones and these
oscillating ones are going to be
difficult to find by hand because you
have to go in and look at every single
memento to figure out what's going on so
this is what our tool is here to help
you identify and note that you know a
very small percentage just a couple we
found that we're always off so what
types of different ways can we detect
these off topic pages so the first thing
we need to do is we need to go from an
archive at collection to terms because
we're going to use the terms in the
webpage to figure out if the memento is
on topic or off topic so we grabbed the
seed you our eyes from the front end of
our private and we get the time map of
the seed your eyes from the CDX well now
I note that we have a we have a
essentially a mirror of archived it from
about two thousand three and so we're
doing our processing for these
experiments on our local copy so then
actually you get the time maps we get
the HTML from the work files use the
boiler pipe library to extract the text
and then we do you know your typical
term analysis
a couple libraries and stemming and stop
word removal we looked at six different
similarity metrics so we looked at once
based on textual content we did the TF
IDF and did cosine similarity of that we
looked at the intersection of the 20
most frequent terms Jaccard similarity
coefficient then we also looked at a
semantics based version basically with
the eye toward something like that BBC
site where you know it's not going down
but the topic itself has has changed and
then also a couple of structural
differences and I'll see you a couple
examples here so for textual content we
had the these three methods and so these
are two of the pages from the
presidential candidate I showed before
and we're always comparing to that first
memento so we compare you know a
candidate mementos of the first one then
towed this one the similarity between
these is pretty high that we have
different values for the different
methods when we go to the one where the
domains expired now we do the Texan
mullerian at 0 for all of them so that's
kind of an obvious candidate the other
thing we wanted to look at was on pages
like for example the BBC you may have
pages that are on topic but they don't
exactly share the top terms so if you
had a page it had Tahrir Egypt and army
and a page that had Cairo Morsi and
protests you and I would realize that
those are still on the same topic but we
needed to find a way so that the
algorithm could realize that those were
the same topic so what we did is we
submitted these terms to the being
search engine API and ground the
snippets that resulted and then we took
that snippet test and did the
tokenization in terms and then reran a
similarity measure and so here we're
able to get point 7 similarity between
these two pages
and then for structural methods we
wanted to see is there a really cheap
way to do this so for content length we
can just look at the HTTP headers to see
how many bytes have changed and then
it's also pretty easy to count the
number of words so we have the example
here we started out with a hundred words
and then went to 109 even though the
page changed dramatically we're just
looking at you know how many words were
there and so this was a nine percent
increase in the number of words if we go
here to where you get an error page the
number of words is going to
significantly decrease so it went down
to five words and that's a ninety-five
percent decrease so negative 0 point 95
in our example so we built a gold
standard data set to evaluate these six
methods and we went through and we
picked three archival collections occupy
Egyptian revolution in politics and the
Columbia University Human Rights
collection these are all pretty large
collections so we sample seed you our
eyes from them and then we sample the
mementos from those but we still ended
up with 15,000 mementos that we manually
labeled or i should say yes mean
manually labeled and we have these
manually labeled sets if any of you are
interested Alex for the human rights one
you can email us and we'd be happy to
share that with you but right now the
format we have is just a text format and
label one means it's on topic label 0
means it's off topic in our future work
we want to make this be kind of an
annotated or extended time out format so
it's a bit more machine readable so we
evaluated these six methods at 21
different thresholds from 0 to 1 and
like I said before we assume the first
memento was on topic we also combined
two methods using or to find the best
combination method that gave us 15
different test combinations and then
average the results at each threshold
over the three test collections we
looked at five different metrics here
false positives false negatives yes I
always forget which is which this is a
very helpful image in our case false
positives or on topics that are labeled
as off-topic false negatives are off
topics labeled as on topics and so then
we also looked at accuracy f1 score in
the AUC the area are under the ROC curve
and that's looking at the false positive
rate versus the true positive rate and
basically higher is better so what we
found is that cosine similarity
performed really well for the the best
single method if you're only going to
use one we found for these collections
cosine with a threshold of point 15 so
if the pages had a point 15 similarity
or higher we said these are on-topic if
it's points15 similarity or lower these
are probably off topic and since we
manually label these we can compute the
false positives and the false negatives
and we ended up with a AUC score of 0
point nine six one these are sorted by
the f1 score and so we got on pretty
high measures for all of these when we
combined two methods cosine combined
with word count worked out as the best
overall method the nice thing about this
one is that again word count is really
easy right once we've done all the stuff
to be able to compute cosine similarity
we essentially just have to count the
words and so we can combine those
relatively cheaply so then the next
thing we wanted to do was let's test out
this cosine word count method and so
we're going to look at other archive it
collections so we picked 11 archive at
collections and they were a range
governmental event-based theme-based
they had time spans of one week to seven
years
some small and some really large and so
what we what we have is we ended up with
an average precision of point 92 on
these 11 archive at collections and and
I'll just break this down here with the
with the pointer these in this top
section actually had a precision of one
so we detected these number of off-topic
mementos and we manually looked at all
of those and we confirm that though yes
those were all off topics so that's 0
false positives we cannot detect the
false negatives because we didn't look
at every single one of these thousands
of mementos but at least this gives you
a starting point and then down here at
the bottom our algorithm detected no
off-topic mementos which you know we
hope is good right and then the ones in
the middle there were several off-topic
mementos and we did identify a few false
positives here another thing I want to
mention is I have in this table the
affected you are I are so the affected
seeds because you could have one bad
seed right that gives you lots of
off-topic mementos and so we wanted to
look at how widespread are these
off-topic mementos in the collections so
just to summarize kind of what we did
for this study we looked at these six
methods to look at similarity between
mementos and a time map tested them on a
gold standard data set from three or
kvick collections and then evaluated the
best approach on 11 diverse or kyvich
collections and so we found that
combining cosine similarity at threshold
point 10 and change in size using word
count at threshold negative 0 point
eight five gives the best performance
and so again the change in size using
word count this threshold means that if
between the first memento and your
candidate memento the candidate memento
the word count decreased by more than
eighty-five percent then it's likely off
topic
and then we got point 9 to average
precision on these 11 archive at
collections so we built a tool so you
can use this so we have a pet Python
command-line tool it right now just does
cosine similarity and it uses our best
default threshold at point 15 for that
and it all operates on live time map so
we'll go to archive it and actually grab
the time map and it's available on
github here's an example with the
Maryland State document collection you
can actually just specify the archive it
collection ID here and then the
threshold you can change it if you would
like and it goes and grabs the seed list
and downloads the time maps and
downloads the mementos and then we'll
print out for those that it thinks are
off-topic the similarity score in the
URI and my note here states that so this
maryland state docs have you noticed in
our evaluation we said it had zero
off-topic mementos but this test was run
in late 2013 and 2014 which is after the
data set that we have local to ODU so
there are new off topic mementos in that
collection the other thing will we can
allow with this tool is that you can
pick a single time map and detect off
topic pages so then this alleged allows
you to look at time maps not necessarily
in archive it so this will be any time
map that's so way back capable this
should work for and so it downloads
these and then prints out the the
similarity and the URI and so just to
state again we don't remove anything we
don't touch your collections we are just
offering a list of potential things you
might want to look at if you want to
kind of co your your collection so we're
continuing to work on this we're going
to add some enhancements to our tool
we're going to add
similarity methods word count will be
the first one we add the other thing we
want to allow is for you to be able to
run this on your local CDX and work
files if you have your your own local
repository we also want to look at what
are the characteristics of the
collections and the time maps that
affects choosing these thresholds so we
didn't want to create you know here's
the best threshold for the Egyptian
revolution when here's the best one for
human rights we wanted some threshold
and method that would work you know
reasonably well for lots of collections
but there may be something we can
discover that would help you kind of
fine tune these for your particular
collection and then kind of farther out
we want to look at detecting off-topic
seeds in a collection so maybe you've
had people suggest seeds to you and you
know you have a lot of seeds and you
haven't been able to go through and look
at them all to see if they really fit
your collection or not can we use this
type of tool to figure out you know are
these seats that you should include or
not and so that's involved with
determining the aboutness of the entire
collection rather than a time map so
again I thank you and again we we are
grateful for your support and I'll do a
quick plug we just found out on yes
friday that this paper from the result
of this work was accepted at TP dl and
we'll be presenting that later in the
fall so thanks
how long did the algorithm team take to
run when you're doing a for like the
data set because I presume cosine
similarity does take a while to run when
you're doing it on a large collection I
would have to ask yes meeting about that
in terms of yeah because she she ran the
experiment so I don't know how long it
took you and I don't know if Miss
yasmeen has considered but I saw the
kernel based search was pretty
interesting it could be coupled with the
lda for topic detection as well as the
ner for named entities and that could
also be matched to find the similarities
between docs it's just a suggestion I
don't know if that's been right right
and I think that may be helpful also
when you're looking at the entire
collection because yeah we're
considering that you know for a
particular time map hopefully the terms
are not going to change too much but
when we move to a collection it may be
much broader and so we may need to do
some more you know kind of a broader
analysis when we look at all the seeds
in a collection ok the other thing to
mention is you could use this tool with
what not presented because you want to
get the off-topic mementos out of your
collection before you do your thumbnail
summarization what are the consequences
if the assumption that the first memento
is actually on topic proves to be false
so you'd probably get a a long list of
you know not of off-topic mementos and
so one thing that we could this would
require work you know get a cooperation
from the curator to kind of figure out
at what point did your time map actually
go on topic the one of the examples that
we filmed and basically the seed got
added before the site was really live
and so you get the kind of the Apache
default page and so you know we could
add a you know a switch in the code that
lets you specify okay don't start
looking until the 5th momento
or whatever but yeah you basically you
just want to reset it to what is really
zero Michelle why didn't you use sim
hashes in this work because Matt was
using say mattress 12 and you didn't i'm
not i'm not sure exactly why we picked
these so that the thing is is that if
you want to detect we wanted to stay
with terms rather than just kind of
character differences so that you know
because we're trying to do what is the
topic of the page rather than you know
did they just get rearranged so I think
trying to keep these into into terms
fits this particular goal better
you